statements
i can tell you all that it is true that
at certain points of my life i was
actually an agnostic
and i did push um towards that as well
now with regards to sarah she has never
been an agnostic
in fact when we went through those
phases sarah helped us
overcome our doubts and problems on
numerous occasions
so with regards to the rest allegations
i should be addressing them
very shortly
we just heard this man's confession
i did not really
i'm lost for words that people in this
ummah or that claim to be muslim
can actually can actually do that
can actually go out and pretend to be
muslims
to scam muslims take their money and
i've seen a living example of this
of these disingenuous individuals doing
that
and from this i think the case has been
closed on this now
we can this is the final chapter in the
book there's no more
plot the plot won't thicken anymore or
mature
the story ends here but there's some
lessons we can learn from this
and i just want to highlight too one of
them is who to rely on
because allah subhanahu wa
he he tells us
the path of those who you have guided
and allah in another part of
[Music]
so the path of those who you have
favored
are as a part of those historical
figures
who have come and gone and passed the
test the fitna
and whose example we can follow and
whose
sunnah if you like their way has been
legitimized by allah himself
so allah subhanahu wa says
if you love allah then follow me i
either prophet muhammad sallallahu
salaam allah will love you
following the path islam is following
the path of the prophets
prophet abraham millet ibrahim prophet
jesus
moses and of course muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
who is the final messenger and then
after that
you have the sahaba you have the
companions
and the prophet muhammad
the best generation is my generation
then those who follow them and then
those who follow them
and so the first thing we have to learn
from that is that
if you're going to attach your iman your
faith with any person
or any people then that should be with
the prophets
of islam prophets like noah abraham
moses and jesus
who all came to proclaim
to hate the oneness of allah don't
rely on me him her or whoever else is
alive and who can
swerve at any time in any day
so that's that's lesson one lesson two
is is actually directed to these two
individuals or these
group of individuals all of which have
deceived the public
and my question is was it worth allah
says in the quran listen to this
in the verse which is very well known
allah subhana tala says
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
my
what has deceived you about your lord
the most generous the one who created
you
for so worker and a portion proportioned
and balance you literally feel like
fine-tuned
in whatever image you wanted to he put
you together
he composed you you
the way of life i islam and you have
have irene
have you read here are the angels that
are writing what you do
they know what they what you do and that
surely
the good people are going to be in
heaven
and the ones who are bad will be in hell
yes
they will go into the hell fire on the
day of judgment
and they will never be absent from that
day from that hellfire ever again
and what do you what would make you know
what the day of judgement is
and what again would make you know what
they have done
the day when no one will
possess anything over anyone else
[Music]
and that day the command will be for
allah
whatever you were doing your club life
doing this that the other what did what
did it even give you what can the world
offer us
what can the world offer us nothing we
have to think about
the purpose of life
think about the purpose of life why are
we here we can all come back
we can all go back to the purpose of
life and this guy the chapters close on
him
and he still has a chance to repent and
close his account as i'm sure he's going
to do now
our humiliation but for the rest of us
for the rest of us we need to go back to
the path and rely on allah and his
messengers
and rely upon the companions who came
after the messengers
and follow the true guidance and by that
will be
realizing our human basic human function
our purpose of life